And just wrapping things up here, I want to cover a few of
the other special selections besides .enter using a Venn Diagram that
Mike Bostock uses in his great blog post, Thinking with Joins.
We can think of these circles and
their overlap representing the state of things right after our
data bind when we're considering what type of special selection to make.
The left circle here, shown in blue, represents our data file.
In this case data.tsv.
And the red circle here represents our HTML page or
SVG elements on that page indexed.html.
And the intersection between these two represents the HTML elements
currently on our page that have already been bound to and associated with
a row from our data file in the previous join made with .data.
And knowing what I've mentioned about the .enter selection,
everything in this blue corresponds to
all the rows of our data that are not yet present on our webpage.
Which we will then add elements to a webpage for each one.
The purple can be thought of as the update selection.
And while there's not an explicit .update we need to call,
this section simple corresponds to elements already on our page from our
prior selection to the data bind, which you might update their data values, or
their styling implicitly by leaving out a .enter or .exit selection.